this summer historic a commission to  Western psychology to investigate this  site thought to be the last resting  place of HMS field ahead of her  Bicentennial in 2020 so we're really  excited to learn that those  investigations have shown that the  outline of the original mud dog is in  fact here and that's believed to be the  place where HMS Beagle was broken up and  dismantled at the end of her life  HMS Beagle spent 25 years of her 50-year  career here on the river roche in  partnership as a custom sports myself  but she's better known as the ship that  changed everything we know about the  worlds of geography geology meteorology  and Natural Sciences  Roger District Council is planning to  celebrate the 200th anniversary of the  launch of HMS Beagle in May 2020 we're  planning and events to commemorate  everything we know about HMS Beagle at  her association with much of a district